so damn it sleazy teasing taggers
Ottomans punctum before vietze Adubato
variety common da fish cod in Aqaba [ __ ]
game thus their president their PPE
fraction for English loose over the
inland from banana land
a heightened hat hair done Stefan more
three are nude with my all shoes for
America from the he gesundheit
blames me hide and each telephone hand
Christian Sylvia both soil a Christian
Sylvia boo saw it cut him out shows for
industry forum would an Aggie and each
telephone for Edina
Jovana valium on diesel producer Clayton
intact either and Kunigal
in crafts and other food to prompt the
exam they come damn it so Nixon tapes on
Tamara next outs prophetess eto Hamada
Anna in undersea Iran Twiggy fish
Montana bought marrow and flower cotton
so would after a plea in via kite of
elect owners in systems then Colonel so
damn it ethnicity our Father at after
hot asphalt here colleague said coughs
ki MIT FIFA's official version eponymous
Authority
Regina Anissa Kaka mrs. ko Heidi grow
Ruby a politically stable named Sammy
Viscount Camaro corrupt sir Sammy taran
Adarsh well it's caprara
Sammy Mironova na say Sammy Grigio van
Subaru Shivani Oh submissive Oh body
am a sincere obscure una buena Casa
Swiss Cognos scope North Vietnam
dialogue may say opposite he a massive
rod not Cicero protege guinea attack VG
may mush most elusive intend to staffs
mean it Rob's Conybeare attack their
oppose an interest in in Haiti Pomona
ignore it to to Krauss Rosa may allah
moosa moses nashit most ignore it back a
plasma politics Kalima acclimatise
Polishness t na high-tech tara EI knows
new york not at Oakland area since
ishutin prappas narrows dear más abajo
teammate academia in eternity she
thought that Osama night MA - Nikita
yet Ana stability' a turnip should
villainous touhou resistant at the obg
criminality OBT politics key motive of a
Nahanni silly artists I miss him
she puts above the dosa me Elena's
minute Equis at him tankard snake stuff
a fossa hottest Ward her colleague
tassel enemy nutria see muchisimas
gracias ids uno de los grandes Solva
Dada's problem NT nostro debate a public
oh no un país imported Oh con unos Cindy
says des Rio mano completamente UND dos
y con un problema de institutionally
Dharavi si ma no creo que lo que esta
pasando nestos en estos últimos desmos
obliga condon are la violencia condon
are la repression yo tengo Syria's
Goudas even de vente kale actual prey
cómo es qué los manifest and ASIC usin
de Kuroshio nian deseos Claro's de que
su puede ser se la persona de quoi de
para llevar lo que necesito el pase
nestos momentos que un gran dialogo
Nacional para rest a blazer una siert a
normalization vulgar caso creo que lo
neo ropa de seguir a POI and o sin duda
conscious instrumento snake operation al
Pais
en cualquier Castro's evident a que aunt
Ella difficult Alan yo entiendo que el
apoyo de extra momenti difficile pour
ESO si apoyo normalization institutional
creo yes ad a logo nacional creo que
debe ser amis Matta meant a priori
Theriot y con los cinco segundos kami
Cayden como es que tenemos Alta
represent and eggy
Simba men take a Sierra tomar esta su do
hasta la Sol trabajo stink Ultimo's a
nose llenos de actividades de initiative
--is quiero mucho Solaris and sadly him
tank out snake Standish power hot air so
net ski that's what I enemy Newton yaaru
flesh raw spots now out putting cover
and a punny description of each other's
out a pinch nuts but his Parliament and
taxes I'm no asobi share his context boy
he keeps hot ghee butter toast honey ago
mr. platts up the wrong effective now
priced far hi Tito yet those night
bidness pancetta
heist the toggle magazine secret says
dramatist cleanse review over una pesca
e south shot mr. SEO steerage who
monitor yet the tan cry Rustom rata
neither contact control of on a monitor
Ivana Pappas who entered 'no chance to
meet raffia dr. Toulouse Oliver you
possibly on see which means bars almost
monitor ovitch so she G esteem opinions
me Moshe Popovich is Polsky nationalist
severe in the hi T approaches to go via
coup Saguna pavo's dot I go the bay it
was over show up oh my gosh Tim Wise
Thank You Shane a colleague at sneaky
new enemy note your autos present and
key comes are poorly grits here to slant
man that took either self-assess
political Suzy on YT instant are who
were some who see now just recap the
vault contra mad mr. Sampson
transparency contra prácticas SAT
average cocoon do they improve cement as
per the song smash footage in suberin
sir
yeah graph to the Sun dispensers vida
the grand maybe it was a commissioner
appeared Cooper arkhipov whitey when a
contrary minister without the omitted
receive a tender sturdy right lever
sincere soon yard implicado to form a
permanent
Susanoo Parliament Rubio Kasich it
became a farce oh boy yes I need a sound
Condon a simultaneous press on veulent
the lips on right en parte the sultry
dodge the space a fundamental division
eyes in tomato sauce for Sudha
humanitarian news on profunda Chris
Messner apoyo impact Nazario CS
autoridades Dwight e non-guaranteed
anatomy and come CSIS
who subsequent to study ready to deliver
that sow respite and regenerate human
ears roosters ravenica songs they focus
on debris God
vielen dank a colleague and Nyx's in the
house for her colleague open-class
prefieres % IITs el pais mass pobre
America s victim a políticas austere
Ishida's Doran is mas internationales de
una de colossal in West oppressed
assented Odyssey noona clase de gente
que Genesis Valle she owes con dinero de
esta nod o a proyect Oh Sofia lays como
consecuencia la polla Fiona's condenado
a la miseria luke lar Scola Rafi mirrors
de personas Asuna dmoz la receta del
capital is mode a casino millas de Tiano
Slevin una y medio las calles excision
dolare Newfie al presidente yell fin de
política as neoliberals
defense NCO so sanada's por la policía
que esta tambien acusada de Vinc you
lost on grupos armado responsible Dimas
a craze y de casos de valència sexual y
todo esto antes Silencio de la comunidad
International Condon ambos la repression
contra pollo he Tiano yell silence
international compl if a a see a sí
mismo s ASIMO's el final de las
políticas Austria Feliz neoliberals
se como la condo nafion de la deuda para
que el pollo ET on Oh poo a tener un
futuro kindig needa cieaura mogherini
espero que no la tenemos que ser de
menos coal ok Venga en la próxima
legislature ah muchas gracias thank a
colleague oh and pure seasoning high
staff officer up metro cooling in cover
them Haiti in an idea Nick - ow Kiyoshi
taco pasty economica narrows vetoes in
nana coast
grows nasty scar above out so nasty lea
discriminate yeah stigmata Satya
Selassie steamy moderna Cobley
extrusions for truck pushes the put it
in and around catastrophe hurried his
house annually to progress Oviedo vici
cows you know say who show home an
eternal got Astro fun
but I kinda protest Nicole is body
electric a poem on Kanye opera to navel
Adam on a mortgage and oh stop homo
cheat stop nirvana 'no cilia who said to
you dame time on a mo gucchy tamil
naturally cove a private
Durrani dope it nivaldo new name editing
Scapa Moochie the stop wladim - Alana
Alana ProSim in opossum unpack Activa
ODIs extra new high ETO na na hyannis
ileum in spas Roach Anjum that [ __ ]
tryin lu d op soem NASA no Oh bro - nah
- pretty sneaky
oh my Ivana Peru China Grozny ooh more
trees no venereal yo Maura
Audrey Garrity Maura please Cochiti Napa
much concrete no hollow feeling drunk on
the farm in the outskirts of thought
meet Tran Colleen Kelly refer to our
patient for expert eye patricians ahem
that's what my enemy Newton girl Magos
Lutron I'm sorry to say but Haiti could
probably be described as one of the most
immoral states in the world amoral
morality abounds just look at the list
widespread corruption unlawful police
force no government no Parliament come
next year harassment and aggression
against journalists murders rape
discrimination against women LGBTI
classed according to their own laws in
Haiti the same as child pornography and
incest as a reason to deny citizenship
violence against elderly people and
perhaps most of all children unable to
go to school
I think if there's one thing we could at
least try and put pressure on the hate
in government is to try and give young
people the chance to go to school
because there is no progress without
school Camargo Tron Tanganyika Liga
Kelly and we found Hartmut hockey league
in Judah fact only focus even aliens
desert Alamo cotton Thank You president
high representative as we've already
heard Haiti is a country almost on the
brink of collapse economic struggles
have led to violent protests shootings
with dozens of deaths at least 20 people
killed and the hands of the security
forces
and many more have been severely injured
the violence has led to children missing
school and people struggling to access
sufficient food drinking water medicine
and fuel the health sector is facing
shortages in electricity fuel supplies
and inability to reach people in need of
treatment the EU needs to play a real
effort and find a meaningful inclusive
resolution to the current solution
especially addressing concerns around
corruption high tea is an ACP partner
ensuring its sustainable development is
vital if we are serious in effort to
tackle climate change corruption and
chaos their high representative what
leverage are you using given that we
have hundreds of millions of euros
through EDF to push for a political
solution to alleviate the suffering of
the people of Haiti and finally I once
again like to wish you all the best for
your future endeavors and thank you very
much for everything you have done thank
you thank you soon the farm that I was
part of fought with our colleague
Andrea's Ramos food effects on European
premiere this is humanitarian Permanente
NIT un país que cuando uno sorry Cooper
odd Oh di una gran catastrophe natural
ya tiene otra Chrissie sanitary I Yoona
crisis política en un país effective
Amenti de los más pub raised el planeta
que estado monado por la pobres all's
Desigual dad la in Segura dad y
lamentablemente la corruption UNK Don
treinta y ocho mil personas delta r a
moto de dos mil Diez toda via see Nova
car
y es de septiembre estaba bien de una
crisis a violent ax una situación de
valència muy preocupe on teh
precisamente por las protest 'as de la
sociedad
contra el gobierno y la falta de bas de
cemento por ESO creo que esta situación
de más de Cuarenta personas fa Ishida's
a un a Sione's Unidas tres periodicities
asesinato
Thank You Bree endo precisamente estará
well toss tenemos que trabajar para
madeira de la violencia pedir una Salida
política que pasa por la celebración de
unas elecciones transparent a say who
Stas y desde luego pedi Rhea Pillai Udo
MANET area en un país donde el cuenta
por ciento de la población depended la
ayuda a lament area Internacional muchas
gracias y muy buena suerte Senora Acamas
Aria pian hats lay him down under
ethnics this farm via an - Parker fought
meet Rocco league in adinolfi 3d factory
on Slauson
see then take on leggy in fact my sister
Sita Ikki
kikuchiyo navy again suppo vechta so not
Meagan O'Malley Tepera population
adriana un pedo ad get you man you van
Gogh know Calpe stocky only Giorno so to
not stree okie no possum only money got
grabbed a license in tech Venera a dtc
Sankara scabby to meid bambini mangano
VIN duty on ya know comida message la
familia pure b NT odd iet get on mega
bank on of your entertainment oh I don't
you see Tia and on potion on the minnow
book tiara huwway answerde journaling on
a sustained a min de Monte a rager odda
ATC Shinya protease target or Oppo space
so non Tony P a casa second Oh Y dot e
they got oh come miss Selena chin you
need to get you money
do em tell you protested he said ten
radio to Brianna pesto a little minnow
pond to do a back soon it kill your
tanta so no study Phoebe there lay let n
kohung go my penso que busty Cristo
quanto a burrito gee peg post una simply
she'd Amanda beef kiss llamo peg me
Tendo to toe questo we had say
Presidente salute oh no Miss Sally Oh
Omo gay Guinea
Eddie algo don t ha t yo gooey beggars
walk away era yeah she can tell him Hank
- uncle in Castile Dornish in morons
here come via ah please hurry up
we are waiting just take a mic
yes
you can use every monkey what do you
want me to continue as a catch the eyes
chorus most okay yes then common via to
Dean colleague dizzy here font anger may
determine beginnin meet han colleague
pathology from the PP first post special
I couldn't read it here clearly it's a
problem of writing here sorry
yes sir the post post took the popular
idea doc you know very stretchy active
but was it was less interested iike
height a malevolent do business and
equal class of evil evil mistress Ito so
Chiana politically towards if that memo
Sonya who does ma Naru star Tom Poston
Adobe HTV chin up a cheerleader protest
we geeky well miss Rosita so she army
CID Waziristan AHA see Tom Liholiho
Prado and Padre means he who robbed a
brutal recession erratum we time yet
Scott Road Street welcome problem a
Buddha opera Bruna Novica Missy
mr. Kemp since Tommy tell miss Opoku
co-star to semi vest Aki dialogue-driven
Alice Paul Tomo JT so the monster II of
ERISA profit actor problem would say we
observe a huge baby listen Giovanni
buckets of a vest
Osvaldo no hated about autumn he much
deception sociology toward see technique
hoochie
to to--some economics keyboard poor Emma
from nearly be home in Oaxaca reflects
eg or Avenue Mariska Brava may be a
spreadsheet or not oblique we can tax
lien tank then mimic tunics for
colleague and to hold on
Aldrin has cost IRA Compton Donna
petition for colleague enzyme the spot
enemy neuter Ultima Donna president of
perdóname getting him Monstar come on
that old omnis allah first attested ship
park AltaVista fume pond piercer to do
16 josie to a central partnership array
made a tone Calcutta depth Roman in Alta
part per kilometer on alter the present
answer Quintino just activity' Tesh so
des with them but by delta particle case
the memento Cobb arches Parliament de
patata - they could properly or upon
sigasi moderate at international
transparent upon Turkish existing
control a chest or diploma Li Shu
verificar Shaquanda March or carry
[ __ ] flagrant and adjust the menu the
boot mode whether a Sakura decision
yesterday sped ripped anomaly she's /
compromise a gossamer just resolved re
and kata more Subramanyam German to
church as for coupon outcome
thank you sir noon her colleague Acosta
no patrician enemy notice I am the spot
Grazia presidentís over to toe Bella
come Prince yo Nelly protest a ET que de
nada mission del Presidente jovenel
moise Ivana wanted a yo-yo la revolt the
la population Adriana in its shadows
Iguodala can chill Dodson is receding
we're not even should car Bronte on pure
Corrado control of escala condition
impossible fundamental international
ever fairy party in piasa
the affected Equestria visualization us
entity in media DeMint a son studied
Eva's stunt a dream eternal associates
with carbon aunty said jr. difficult at
the Devon to the Lombardo impasto that
is a unity al Venezuela a put it was to
disaster another deficient imaginary IET
L Pacific poverty miss Farrow August
increase no contest with a the Sicilian
study complementary the majority
compensation a vault a protege party P
venerable a populist shown the president
was non Semra very intentional
earth-shattering categorical moment own
ad abandon are a la presidents in a
politican Oliver Alli esta audit on de
la soie and chiropodist at unity adele
core group and could grupo de casa de t
immediate Rakuten repair colleg gentle
momento de cambiar la política a primer
on common to register a burger until
equity a juice its fairness tree
initiate eonni Thank You Shannon and
found without meat and colleague Paul
check from the PPU the equipment
iachino abrasca Ontario Bratislava
sericea heights Kissin Arturo's
cheerleaders who said led me Toto soo
brass contrast Oh Brava
nah height a contrast amazi hood Obama
prosto hood Obama hottie Romani do
legite also decorated non-homogenous
aqua a national protest a widow
selection process krump Ivana rajim a
president of a jovenel moise OV a
packrat reproduce at gross toad season
but Robin pallava
a bientot hoto possum Oh Rebecca Nia
Eskil Evelyn Wright a yeas are even
cheaper m- rock morena Vanaja give us
average any proper Asif index of Quran a
novena who is a Buddha browser yotsuba
novice at the Alex opposite C to become
nearly as nice cars at Heights garage
official suit corrupt sale as a muse its
nazar coordinates caprara lead enema
each who east appeal a total newbie the
home mr. Asti heights kavadi upon be so
obsessed of it was a bigger pop chart
shake not Obrador show possible a
palooka by disease which boasts the
Arabs comedic we thank you soon on tan
common via amara egg and an up Cartman
before I won't fat little enough notice
what a tie and of Hockey League in
war-torn a Sunday thank you very much
president for two months Haiti has been
engulfed in protests which were
triggered by fuel shortages and quickly
turned violent
morphing into a campaign against the
president according to UN figures more
than Li sorry according to UN figures at
least 42 people have been killed and
dozens injured during these
anti-government protests violence is
fueling further insecurity in an already
fragile state
wracked with poverty inequality and
corruption more than one in three
hydrogens need urgent assistance to meet
their daily food requirements meaning
that nearly 3.7 million people are going
hungry
yet aid organizations are struggling to
provide relief to those most in need the
EU must work with the Haitian
authorities to provide urgent
humanitarian assistance
another deplorable act of violence
that's occurred during this unrest his
violence against women in state prisons
where women are detained in the same
cells as men and subject to rape here in
the European Parliament we're marking
the 16 days of action to end
gender-based violence
so let's not forget these vulnerable
women in one of the poorest countries in
the world finding locally lean and
absolute style father had asked for to a
federated and petition for Commission
mogherini home this world the poorest
country in the Americas is now paralyzed
by a crisis that is political as well as
social and economic large segments of
the population are protesting against
the way the country is currently
governed and particularly against
corruption and mismanagement cases that
have involved high figures in the
institution's young activists are at the
forefront of the protests but farmers
and shopkeepers have also joined and
after years of economic crisis the
country is now facing a constitutional
crisis - with no government and no
Parliament's the protests started some
of you have mentioned over fuel
shortages with the summer they're now
paralyzed in the country businesses
hospitals schools government
institutions are often closed transport
throughout the country has become very
complicated including 40-man italian
aids and the country is basically at a
standstill political stances are getting
more radical the amman italian crisis is
worsening and gang-related violence is
also on the rise we have been and
constantly are following very closely
the current crisis coordinating with the
countries and institutions from the core
group we also have urged the authorities
to conduct effective and thorough
investigations into crimes the
authorities must guarantee the rights to
demonstrate freely and peacefully
and violence must be avoided under all
circumstances I expressed this position
on behalf of the 28 member states
earlier this month we also called on all
actors to engage in a national dialogue
to identify consensual solutions to the
current crisis in its political economic
and humanitarian dimensions
let me also recall that the European
Union is also coordinating with other
donors to provide urgent relief inside
the country because the humanitarian
situation is dramatic yet the current
situation is clearly unsustainable it's
not only a matter of humanitarian aid
it's a political process that can create
the conditions for the international
community to support the country's
long-term developments Senor Presidente
me Constanta / concluded instituto do
series re la lingua Kosaku photo
Elementary in West ome chic low / Ingrid
CRA do not EEMA colaborate Cernik AB
Yamamoto lungo questi Cinque on me he
needs you the wisdom and Otto Parliament
RA in questa me may see a eco leggy
parliamentary or opaque assumed study in
questa banky and a quatrain yamigedo
president o sempre dato extrema
importance or Rollo della diplomat see a
parliamentary friend okay roll O'Dell
parliamentary up a osya fundamentally
non so tanto Perla Democrat zebra para
mantener in Ostrava Roper La Paz la
cigarettes ax
una política ester a corporate even el
mundo super to toe in questa mondo DOJ
every since elementary Ingrid Sierra Mme
des parlamento
2t e Presidente EVC Presidente
to T groupie politician particular lead
wakame Sony con la cual EO Bhutto
piacere di levar a few Street Ament a
commission affair est la camisa nice
velu po che ha no sempre sostenuto
Amado fundamental in your Ligurian
question grazie Mille
Oh whoever catering mogherini is Slovak
in Nam and this Hampton houses Sucre him
that's Mickey Nam this houses by Union
but and a few lattissima but MIT in
Parliament other often and cracking than
ultrason ever naturally awfully and has
only and that's video hope you own your
own food Edie updates ISM are by the
multi lateral and Institute soon and
camtonz hearts leaking tank foodies
arbitral forum of a diesel engine of
teasing it's like Tom Thank You Sean
some apps was the old quarter wardens X
and flea songs Antigua younger right
Jesus X Antigua kanji of the website at
his Parliament's I mean the Alpha
estimate gosh Lawson and hunt abrasion
is it song mr. upstream on come elf what
I see
Thank You Sean